[Musique]
vous ne le vois comme ça tu te dis
franchement ça peut être mon conseiller
financier ouais mais bon j'aime bien et
pas trop du club libertin l'hippocampe
hippocampe exactement bah ouais mais on
a un sauna hammam jacuzzi one ou alors
est-ce que vous avez déjà reçu des
personnalités
oui dans votre établissement on a un
masque dans votre et dérision non non
non quand ils commettent mais je suis
fermé depuis le 14 mars la dernière fois
le 26 novembre d'ouvrir trois y avait
quoi j'ai voulu rouvrir parce que moi je
suis pas une boîte de nuit fâche pas un
unique je fais sonam a besoin de peu de
suite vous faites très peu de musique la
plancha
on a des gens des gens connus qui
viennent aux idées des hommes politiques
des prénoms autour de la table qui est
allé chez vous oui on n'aurait pas qui
c'est non parce qu'il ya une histoire de
privé c'est à dire que le chat un chat
c'est un état d'esprit à bien sûr et je
pense que monsieur la salière qui a fait
cette remarque il faut être honnête
aujourd'hui c'est un peu les peaux crise
il sait très bien que les hommes
politiques comme les présentateurs télé
ou les choix et la balance et voulez
vous savez les présentateurs télé qui
sont venus les assistants des chanteurs
des acteurs confisquer les portables là
bas alors non il nous arrive une
histoire je voulais raconter c'était
sous l'ère sarkozy
monsieur sarkozy nous avons un homme qui
nous a laissés un portable à l'accueil
que monsieur était très sympa une loi
lagarde et moi mon portable très posé et
puis un moment le téléphone a sonné on a
vu afficher sur le portable au bar
monsieur le président sarkosy donc on
s'est dit tiens c'est important ça va
être important donc on a été chercher le
monsieur en plein ébats et on lui a dit
que le portable avait sonné et que l'on
pouvait pas dire ce qui était affiché
parce que halo et puis donc
était certainement quai après on l'a
reconnue donc voilà ouais été manquée
scanner doit politique oui ce matin j'ai
regardé l'intervention de monsieur la
salle mais j'ai regardé aussi votre
émission sur discothèque
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a un
gouvernement qui n'a pas compris que un
commerce et un commerce
aujourd'hui on parle des clubs libertins
parce que monsieur la salle a fait cette
intervention il faut savoir que j'ai
écrit plus de 45 vous pourriez
recommandé premier ministre et non
olympiques j'ai jamais eu de réponse
comme par hasard
sk différence très intéressé je trouve
une fois je suis allé une fois fallait
quand même que je vois ça ah oui c'était
génial à l'eau valérie doré ça sent
mauvais mais j'adorais c'est bien plus
didier exprès donc maison par commune
hérité ça balance pas mal et franchement
non c'est vrai nom voilà que ce soit
chez ou ailleurs et je serais quand même
je me dirai pas mené à la journée mais
oui alors j'ai passé